A Quiet Place is packed with many tense, nerve-shredding
moments, however, one special scene between
John Krasinski and Emily Blunt is loaded with
much more meaning than you might realise.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I'm taking a deep dive into A Quiet
Place to explain the secret story behind the
movie's earbud scene and why director John
Krasinski insisted it had to be in the movie.
Spoilers ahead if you haven't seen the film
yet!
In the earbud scene, Emily Blunt's Evelyn
and her husband Lee take a moment for a slow
dance together and, in doing so, briefly tune
out the horror of their everyday life hiding
from the sound-sensitive aliens that threaten
them.
It's a very tender moment and, as the two
parents sway together, Evelyn takes out one
of her earbuds and shares the song she's listening
to with Lee.
The song is "Harvest Moon" by Neil Young and
it's the only song that plays in the movie.
The curious thing about this song choice is
that it's a very expensive song to license
and, given the film's tight budget, it wasn't
something the production could really afford.
However, for Krasinski, who wrote this scene
as part of his rewrite of the original script,
it was vital to have this specific song in
the movie.
According to producer Andrew Form, Krasinksi
"would not stop until we got that song."
So, why was it so important for Krasinski
to play this expensive song in his relatively
low-budget movie?
Well, first of all, it's a very personal track
for Krasinski and his real-life wife, Emily
Blunt, as two of their close friends got married
to the song.
In fact, on the first take the couple shot
of that intimate scene, Krasinski looked up
and saw not only he and Blunt "were crying
at the exact same time", but their crew were
also welling up.
And beyond that personal connection, there
are also multiple levels of meaning to the
song itself.
Neil Young, who wrote and performed "Harvest
Moon", has said that it's about "this feeling,
this ability to survive and continue and grow
and get higher than you were before.
[…] You can be MORE alive" which, as I explained
in my Quiet Place ending video, is a key theme
in the movie – how a family not only survives
an alien invasion, but aims to thrive and
grow in spite of it.
Over the years since its release though, some
have interpreted the song as more bittersweet,
being about a love that endures even when
a couple are no longer together.
The line "When we were lovers, I loved you
with all my heart" could hint at two people
who are separated.
And so the song could foreshadow the heartbreaking
events later in the movie when Lee sacrifices
himself to save his family, with the lyrics
implying that Lee and Evelyn will still remain
connected in spirit even though he's gone.
On top of that, a Harvest Moon is the full
moon that occurs closest to the autumn equinox,
and usually coincides with the September or
October full moon.
And, as we see on the family's calendar, the
due date for the Abbots' new baby is the day
before the October full moon.
Traditionally, the Harvest Moon also had special
meaning for rural communities, like in A Quiet
Place, because it meant there was plenty of
moonlight even after sunset which helped when
harvesting crops at that time of year.
And it fits in with the idea of the seasons
of life, again foreshadowing how Lee's life
will be coming to an end.
All-in-all, the song is a bittersweet and
tender moment for the couple as they savour
some brief time together and anticipate the
arrival of their new baby.
It's also an instant of respite for the audience
watching the movie as the silence fades out
and we can relax with a gentle song before
the full horror of the family's fate kicks
in.
And adding another layer of meaning to the
song is the fact that Neil Young made his
Harvest Moon album at a time when he was suffering
from tinnitus and couldn't listen to any loud
noises.
Young had damaged his hearing while working
on an earlier album and concert tour, which
makes the song even more appropriate for A
Quiet Place.
Now, just for a bit of fun, fans of John Krasinski
in The Office may also link the Quiet Place
earbud scene with the time that Jim shared
his earbuds with Pam in a similarly romantic
moment in season 2 of the popular show.
I don't know whether Krasinski had that sweet
Jim and Pam moment in mind when he wrote this
scene in A Quiet Place, but either way it's
a nice call-back for fans of the show.
So, did you spot any other hidden meanings
in A Quiet Place and what do you think about
the earbud scene?
Leave me a comment with your thoughts below
and you can also tweet me.
To discover more about A Quiet Place, tap
left to check out my full ending and creatures
explained video and tap right for my breakdown
of the movie's deleted scenes.
If you enjoyed this, hit the like button and
subscribe for more of my videos!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers!